foreign
continuing in our journey through zed
this as we mentioned before is one of
the most
pivotal and important books in the
history of islamic library
that is that ibn al-qaeda almost
encompassed the entirety of the sunnah
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in this book
it can almost be said if it's not in
zadil mahad
it's not part of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
almost we don't say that for any book
not sahih al-bukhari not muslim
because no one person knows all of the
sunnah
except for the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
it is impossible for any one person
to encompass the entirety of the sunnah
illabi he said whoever claims that he
knows
all of the sunnah then he is incorrect
and that statement is false the only one
that can
encompass the entirety of the sunnah is
the prophet himself
but as we mentioned before
it is a very very pivotal book it's an
important reference
it's a reference for everyone who came
after him
with regards to the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam sunnah
biography the way that he did things
harmonizing different narrations that
seem to clash
an explanation of all of his days
and times
we were speaking about the
way that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would perform
funeral prayers
[Silence]
it's narrated that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would not praise hola geneza
over anyone who had committed suicide
or anyone who had stolen from the spoils
of war
before it was distributed what does this
mean
means that after a battle
all of the spoils of war are to be taken
everything
everything even if it's a shoestring
all of them are compiled and then they
are distributed by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam or the
general
in command whoever takes something
before this distribution this is called
rule
and el hulul is one of the most major
sins
and it invalidates martyrdom
subhanallah and if a person steals from
the war booty before it is distributed
and they are killed in battle they will
be
their martyrdom will be invalidated
subhanallah
[Silence]
they claimed that some person was a
martyr but the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said
actually he is not a martyr i saw him
being tortured in the fire because
of a cloak that he stole from the war
booty
allah
[Silence]
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
would not make salat el geneza he would
not lead salat in geneza
over somebody who committed suicide or
somebody who stole from the spoils of
war
this doesn't mean that nobody would pray
soleit el geneza
somebody would pray solatill geneza the
companions would praise holla till
janessa
all it means is that his salah
they would be deprived from it as a kind
of
punishment and as a kind of
rebuke to the rest of everybody that
don't do these things because if you do
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
may not make salah
upon you now a person may listen to this
and say subhanallah
[Silence]
likewise the prophet salallahu
would make solateal genes over somebody
who had died
from el christos meaning somebody killed
someone
and then was was executed in return
or somebody had committed
major adultery and they were for example
executed for that the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam after
this had would be done he would make
salah
upon the person why because this had
will expiate that sin that the person
committed
if a person commits a sin let's say a
person
steals and has his hand cut off
this expiates the sin khalas this person
is no longer considered a thief
he has paid his dues so the prophet
salallahu alaihi
[Silence]
and when he would make solatil janeza
over anyone
he salallahu alaihi wasallam would
follow or accompany
this geneza this funeral procession and
he would usually walk
ahead of the genes
and likewise
this is what they would do as well if
they made somebody
they would follow that geneza and
oftentimes they would walk
ahead of the geneza now keep in mind
that the graveyard was
walking distance right it's better to
walk
to a funeral it's better than riding
and in some narrations the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam prohibited
that if a person is riding to go ahead
of the funeral
you have to be behind the actual geneza
but if you're walking you can walk ahead
of the geneza
now this is pertaining to a geneza
that is in with within walking distance
obviously in a place this the
the cemetery is not in walking
distance
so we're not going to walk we're all
going to drive right
but all of us that when we drive we are
taking the
reward of somebody who is following the
funeral procession
if indeed we do follow the funeral
procession
if a person prays for that geneza they
are rewarded
and if they pray salat el janesa and
follow the geneza
until it is buried they are doubly
rewarded
and they are given twice the reward of
the person who merely makes salat el
janeza
ibn al-qayyim then goes into mentioning
the issues of how many tesleem
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would make on saleh
it was narrated that he would make one
teslima assalamu alaikum
just that and it's mentioned that
he would make both tesleem as well
as both are correct
and both are authentic if you notice
it's important that a person not
cause strife amongst people
if they are all united right
we should not cause strife amongst
people that are united upon something
what does that mean well if we have a
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam that the people
always practice right we should not
shock their minds and cause discord
by introducing them to something that
they are
not aware of and don't have to do
so for example i know the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
used to make one teslim and he used to
make two teslin
here in this masjid for example or in
this community we always make two
tesleem
right so i come and i make one to sleep
and now everybody's uproar what is
happening what's going on i said no it's
the sunnah of the prophet
and then we have two groups we have one
group who's with me and one group who's
against me and now everybody's
over what
as long as people are not doing
something haram
we are not going to introduce anything
to them that is going to shock their
minds
this is something that the scholars
warned us
of when we were in our earliest days of
seeking knowledge
[Silence]
this is something that is clearly
prohibited
if people are all committing something
that doing something that is the sunnah
they're not committing a major sin
they are not and they are all collected
on that issue and in agreement you're
not going to come along and divide
them with something that is preferable
or something that is a difference of
opinion or something that is
most of the time not all of the time
most of the time people that do this
they do this for attention huh
they do this for attention and you find
people usually use the khutba for these
kinds of things
they get up on the mimbar and they start
going into detailed discussions on
issues that are different upon limada
this is not what the khatwa is for
the should be the most elementary
understood by the most ignorant person
that attended jummah
if the most ignorant person if a
non-muslim came to your khutbah and
understood it and understood the message
that means you gave the khutwa correctly
it should not be fancy it should not be
something over the people's heads it
should not be something that is
articulate and takes a lot of
concentration
all of the khutbahs of the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam
were extremely simple and based on the
main
issues of islam
tawheed saleh
warning from the hellfire glad tidings
of paradise descriptions of paradise the
five pillars of islam
this is what the khutwa is for the
khutba is not
for a discussion or a disposition on
some fil issue that
is debated and you know something that
does not belong in the lapse of
everybody who's listening that is
incorrect
that is not how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam use the mimba
that is not how the companions
use the member the member is to educate
people it's the only
obligatory class or lecture that you
must attend every week
in all of islam that's the only
obligatory
binding lecture that you have to attend
and so you are going to attend that
lecture
and that lecture is going to
it is going to reflect
what you need to get through your week
upon the piety of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
it is too
it is that is the should be built
and designed so that
everybody who attends benefits something
in their personal life something that's
really going on
because sometimes some of the people
given khutbah are living in a different
universe than the rest of
all of us right and i'm sure we've all
attended hatwas that
alhamdulillah here at this masjid we
don't have that problem
but in some massage it in some places
the khatrib is on some other planet
talking about something that does not
apply to anybody who's there
right or applies to two or three little
small
clicks of people that are there and the
rest of everybody understood nothing of
what is being said
or benefited by nothing it should be
extremely consequential
to anybody who hears it just the
quran
the quran any part or meaning that is
heard
automatically articulates its point
in the most rudimentary fashion
just when the prophet salallahu
sallam would recite the quran to
non-muslims and it would apply to them
right this is how the should be
the next thing even al-qaeda goes into
is the issue of
making salat
before this he mentions
[Silence]
and whoever misses initially
the slate
then they should make solatil geneza or
they can make solateal genasa
over the grave itself right
so let's say you came from some other
area to make solatel genasa but you miss
solatill
and then janez is already on its way to
the graveyard
you can make solatil janaza at the
graveyard
you can make it at the grave and this is
the only salah that is
acceptable or valid in the graveyard
otherwise all salah
is invalid in the graveyard it is haram
categorically to praise saleh in any
graveyard
however solate el geneza is the only
exception to that
that a person stands over the grave and
makes soleta geneza this is only
if a person accidentally misses it
it is not something by design and it is
not something that should be
repeated often i mean if we look at the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and his legacy we see in medina he lived
for 10 years
and he made how many genes at that time
yet only one or two times it was
collected that he made solitaire geneza
over the grave
it should be something that is almost
non-existent
it shouldn't happen often and it should
not be a habit
he says walemya
he said and it was not part of the
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
to make in sure over the person who
is away each time
what does that mean somebody who is
muslim or we get the news that somebody
dies in another land so we make salat el
janeza
without the actual body this is called
salat
we're making salat el janeza without the
actual body
right this is something
that is only selectively done
and it's only by a certain amount of
conditions for a person to make this
kind of salah
matters
[Silence]
should only be performed under one of a
couple
of circumstances number one
the first circumstance is somebody who
is muslim
dies in a land that is
void of other muslims to make salat el
janesa
meaning they die in some land and we are
sure that nobody made solatul janezza on
him
this is the same thing that happened
within najashi and najashi
was the king of ethiopia
right and he was
a muslim he became muslim
but he was unable to announce his islam
because of the fallout that would occur
and he passed away
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was informed in medina
of and najashi's death and he made s
we stand just as we do for regular salan
we make solatel janeza that's it with
the intention that it is for
this particular individual another
situation
where it may occur
is when we are unable to have access
to the body itself this happens
sometimes even here in america
right let's say somebody passes away
who is muslim yet because of legal
reasons
the muslims are unable to make solatill
the family members are non-muslims they
won't allow the muslims to make salat el
geneza
they take the geneza and let's say they
cremate him
right or let's say they do whatever
because they have
the legal ability to do so
in this situation we can make salah
right this is what it is designed for
is not designed that every time somebody
dies in another place we make
no matter who he is right
why is that because
when we look at the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
we see hundreds of companions who died
in other lands
and he didn't make salah whether they
died as martyrs or whether they were
lost
or whether they died in travel wherever
they died they were buried
right they would not be shipped back to
medina
wherever a person died he would be
buried
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would be informed of his death
and he would not make salah because
the people that buried him or the
caravan he was with or the muslims that
were around him already did that
so it should be used
and applied very selectively wallahu
[Silence]
he said and likewise as collected by
imam muslim in his authentic compilation
it was of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam sunnah that he would not bury
anyone
when the sun is rising or when the sun
is setting or when the sun is in the
center of the sky
at the middle of noon before it crosses
its
[Silence]
in his sunan that's the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would take three
handfuls
of dirt and throw them on the
on the body when it is placed in the
grave at the burial time
three of them at the head area
of the deceased this is what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would do
a little a little issue about burying
the body
sometimes people find that you know in
current times
we use you know
current we use equipment to bury
people
right so we have bulldozers or
tractors right and we just
pour the dirt on the grave some people
have a problem with that they say ani
how how can we have a tractor yeah i
need put the dirt on the person
yes we have a tractor put a dirt on the
person because
it's easier because it's technology that
allah gave us and there's no disrespect
in that
right if you you know the same thing is
the technology of the time was shovels
and that's what people used
why should we take an hour and a half to
shovel in
all of the dirt when we can just have it
put on
the body all at once with with
technology that's essentially a big
giant shovel
right so these are
myths or things that people have in
themselves
they feel it's disrespectful or
it's not correct
there's nothing wrong with that at all
sometimes yani
we go to certain funerals and people
will tell me okay just have the guy put
the
dirt next to the grave and we'll shovel
it in no we're not going to do that
so there is no reason why
a person cannot just use a bulldozer or
use a tractor or any
current technology to put the dirt on
the grave
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam they used whatever
technology they had
and we now have other technology that we
use as well there's no disrespect in
that and there's no
opposition to the sunnah in that
he says
upon completion of burying the deceased
he would stand there over the grave him
and his companions
and he would ask allah and make dua that
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
keep this person firm in his faith when
being asked
and questioned in his grave
[Silence]
each person would usually make dua on
his own
but sometimes jani it is okay to add to
that
it doesn't have to be restricted to only
that dua
this is what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam commanded
other companions
mentioned in their will that please
after you are finished burying me
stand around the grave long enough for
camels to be slaughtered yani
what does that mean that means that
stand around my grave and make dua
for an extended period of time for me
so this is a sunnah that a person make
dua
for the deceased at the cemetery over
the grave and
if a person is making dua and others are
making
saying ameen along with him there is no
problem in this insha allah
[Silence]
usually we have people at the graveyard
you know they will
say you know somebody one person
right will say al-fatiha and then
everybody will raise their hands and
recite
and then wipe over their face and body
this is something that was never
narrated from the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam ever he never ever did
that once
nor he nor any of his companions
and
often times when i attend funerals
after i'm done speaking after dua people
look at me and say in fat
huh and i tell them the same thing i
just told you right now
and then you have some people that will
do it and other people that won't do it
it's a traditional thing it's not a part
of the son of the prophet salallahu
[Silence]
another thing that is incorrect is that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would never
raise any graves and it's mentioned that
he would never raise a grave more than
about a shiver which is a hand span
when we're talking about raising a grave
we're not talking about
the dirt that we put on the grave when
we bury them
when we bury somebody the dirt is going
to be high
and it needs time to settle we're not
talking about that
what we're talking about is purposely
building up the grave to where it sets
high putting stones on top of it or what
is called taste
putting a roof over it or making
a dome over it or any of these things
putting lights on it putting candles on
it
putting anything on it that would
distinguish it from other graves
other than identifying who is in the
grave
this is something which is prohibited in
islam
[Silence]
a
lima
[Silence]
i
foreign
[Silence]
you